all right so your actual name is azraya
yeah not exotic exotic is your street
name yeah so just from now on i'm
calling you azraya
but my audience knows you as exotic
and you had a heartbreaking interesting
story that we that i posted maybe a
month or so ago
so a lot has happened since that first
talk right
tell me what's going on
um well i haven't been
like out working or any of that at all
um at all
um i've had a few people hit me up and
like that i used to work with
you've had a lot
i've been messaged by about 10 pimps
that wanted to like want me to introduce
you to them
and i've been messaged by like my old
pimps and
like ex-boyfriends and stuff like
people i used to work with and
it's just like sometimes it'll be like
okay
yeah
you know the kids could probably use a
little extra money or something but
then i'll like think about it and it's
just like okay you haven't done it for
this many days so i you know just throw
it all away and go back and do it it's
been like over a month now right
yeah
that's great
and you're staying you're staying now
far from the hood yeah
with your with your boys
your two beautiful sons yeah
that's going to be nice for them right
[Music]
yeah you're doing a lot of things right
you know you and i speak a lot
and uh
i you know i've helped people a lot but
with you i see
it seems like your head and your heart
are in the right place
[Music]
and you and you seem like intelligent
enough to like make good decisions
and and i see you kind of doing it now
which is great so it's easy to help you
now
it was hard but
i mean
it's worth it
so tell me a little bit about your story
you uh
there's more to your story than you
shared in that in that first talk we had
you you have you have a pretty extensive
gang
background right
yeah
tell me about that that was pretty heavy
right it wasn't just like you know these
guys or they're your pimps but you
actually were involved
yeah
um like i've had
ex-pimps i guess you could say that
are from
where i'm from and
they've also like been trying to get in
contact
but it's just like uh
we have your kids to raise now just tell
everybody that yeah
and like some of them understand it and
then some of them are just like so
selfish and
just like
self-centered like i don't know how else
you could put it but you know they don't
care about nothing else except for them
and what can benefit them you know
i guess hood mentality yeah and you're
what i see you doing is thinking for
your you know doing things for you which
will help your kids you're spending a
lot of time with your boys which is
great
so tell me who's who is the uh
the father of your voice
um the father of my boys um
he's uh he's been
in prison now for a couple
few years
and
i met him
running away from placement
not trying to go back to juvie for a
violation
like not going to school or whatever
and
like long story short he ended up being
a registered sex offender and all this
other stuff because you were underage
um
no he was already a registered sex
offender before
yeah before he met you
yeah so every charge he got with me was
like
like they doubled it
because he was already uh
like
he was already uh offender so you were
you were whole when you were with him um
i was about like
13 when we started talking
and
i got pregnant
with my first son when i was 16 had him
when i was 17
and then got pregnant by him again when
i was 18.
so he's gonna be in prison for a long
time yeah for about like 47 years
four months and he's already like 40
something so
yeah
but your boys are beautiful
thank you they look just like you
they're like clones of you
they really get that along both of them
and how are you doing with drugs
um a lot better crystal meth use is
you're cutting back yeah a lot
like i've went from
like feeling like i couldn't wake up
without it
to cover up stuff that i was doing to
like now i hardly ever think about it
then when i do like it's not that hard
to
like get rid of like it's not a
very hard habit to shave
yeah it's probably easier than
fentanyl heroin or crap
and how are you emotionally with all of
this this new life you're living
it's been
like a roller coaster ride like some
days are
easier and better like better than
others i guess you could say
like sometimes i find myself
like just depressed and just sleeping
moping through the whole day
and i really
won't even know what's really wrong with
me i it's just
you know something that i feel well
you've been using crystal meth for a
long time right yeah
for years right yeah so cutting back
cutting that out is going to make you
your body's going to go some your mind
your brain is going to go through
through some adjustments yeah a lot of
thinking
well you have a lot to think about
that's why i wanted to put you in where
you could
perhaps think more clearly than than
staying in the hood where you were when
i
first met you
and uh i don't know that your thinking
is really gonna change that much it's
certainly not a good environment for
your boys yeah so
so you're in a totally new environment
living a very different life
we'll see where it goes from here
but you it's encouraging
you're doing some of the right things
and that's great
do you have any you have any thoughts on
what you'd like to do um
well like i said my brother had sent me
a post
about writing a book yeah your story
would be a great book
yeah
so
i mean i've started like here and there
and then i get sidetracked
there's a lot of people i've interviewed
that have great stories that would make
for books movies whatever there's
there's a pimp who i
am friends with who's
just told me this morning actually he's
got a i think a movie or tv show being
made about his life story
he's got a great story your story is
amazing
eric who i've interviewed has a great
story he has a book where he's working
on
there's a bunch of them so
yeah your story would be great
and you're a writer right you like to
relate to write
that sounds like a great idea yeah
are you boys enjoying spending more time
with you yeah
it's different it's definitely different
like
from
like i
went from
i can not even checking in on them
for a certain amount of time to
like just feeling
like empty without them
you know
so it's like when they're not with me i
call texts check on them
but
your mother
it's way different than you know like
being high and just
like
almost like i guess
pushing it away you know like
definitely different from like
being high and numb so you know you
don't really pay that much attention to
the fact that you know like hey i'm
somebody's mom and somebody depends on
me like
like not even a want but you know like
they need me
your boys need you for sure
you have no family really left
to help you right yeah
it's all on you
your boys are going to do fine with you
i think you're a great mom
thank you
you probably see things very differently
very clearly now that you've been you're
like removed from that environment
removed from that lifestyle
especially where you're staying it's
it's a whole nother world yeah people
are going to work they're doing
normal things normal things yeah
the hoods the the hood is the streets
are
another world
yeah
and you've been there for
most of your life probably
[Music]
do you have any friends
that you stay in contact with
what about all your your homies from the
from the gang
um
i have like one that i could actually
consider like
like
at least close to a friend you know but
i wouldn't say like a friend as far as
from the set
i mean other than that like i would say
like you you know like
we talk a lot
well i'm like when i'm out at four or
five in the morning editing you i'm on
the phone talking with you
yeah
now this is a great opportunity for you
to
break the cycle
yeah
at 23 right
it's a perfect time for you to
to do this you seem to be the right
personality to do the right thing you're
not like some of the other people i've
interviewed who are just like
maybe saying the right thing but not
doing it i i see how you've
you've walked a very straight line since
i met you since that video
a lot of people wanted to help you
and the gofundme on my channel is
probably a great way to
continue to support
israel to
to be in a safer part of town and
give her the opportunity to you know
have transportation get to work do
whatever she wants to do
support her kids all that so if you guys
want to donate to that that would help
but that's what i've been doing is
helping her
to help herself and help her kids
and it's nice to see somebody doing it
the right things so i'm proud of you
thank you
any uh
any thoughts about
have you spent the last 10 years of your
life
like i
said a few times before like just
talking to other people about
you know about it like
like my little brother seeing the video
my niece seen the video
it's just um
like i can say that i've
come from
being very reckless and
careless
with like not only my life but
my kids
to
like i don't know i guess you could say
like
trying to do its
best now and what's right instead of
just
doing whatever's out there to
do quick fast you know like
i could say that that was a big issue
before like
any way i could get money
i was trying to get it and the fastest
way
but you know sometimes
you just gotta
just chill
and you know
do right and not just move fast yeah now
you've been doing it
you get a lot from doing that instead of
just
like i said being careless you know
i mean that like in the moment we don't
find it like being
careless like you know it's
it's what we know
to survive you know like especially not
having no help no family
like sometimes you know all we be
needing is somebody to talk to
and so when we don't get it we just go
and look for it somewhere else
all right well i'm going to continue to
help you out
and change you your life a little bit
proud of what you're doing though
because you're doing the work
and sometimes it you know i i've given
people help like this
and they say all the right things but
what really gets in the way eventually
is their ability to accept
a better life
that's the real hurdle and that's why so
many of these stories don't really turn
out
the way they should or the way we want
them to
is because the person really doesn't
believe they deserve it
it's not about your kids it's really
about you
because if you do it for yourself then
your kids will benefit
but if you do it for your kids i'm not
sure it's all going to stay
where it should
you take care of yourself and everything
else will fall into place
like it was hard
like it still kind of is sometimes
but
like i said it's definitely worth it
like i've changed a lot from
always trying to get into something like
in a negative way like always trying to
fight somebody or you know like
being out on fig
dressing however
i felt like dressing
or like
dressing you know
in a way that would give me a lot of
negative attention
to
like even now like i'm not just like you
know
like fully covered but
i mean
you know it just it feels different in a
better way like
walking down the street just knowing
like okay well you know i don't have
just
butt hanging all out of my shorts or you
know like
somebody could
see me and not just instantly think
about
sex or what they could pay me to do or
you know
like just being able to
interact with somebody
normally like
it feels different
but in a good way
i guess that's what
like used to
scare me a lot too about just leaving
the lifestyle away like not knowing
how to interact with people
other than
how i've
been brought up to interact with people
like it's different but
it feels good just knowing that you know
you respect yourself
and that you don't like
i guess
like just seek for somebody else to
respect you more than you respect
yourself
if that makes any sense
because
like doing this type of stuff like i've
seen a lot of young girls
like
just so insecure and like
like totally lose their self because of
something that
one guy can
feed them and tell them
and they believe it
that's crazy
and i don't know i used to i used to be
like that too for a long time
and like especially after doing drugs
and stuff like that
like i didn't even i didn't value or
respect myself
i guess at a level where i know i can
and i have before
and just i don't know like slowly but
surely it's coming back
it's just
i don't know i guess a lot to take in
it's really yet
you just it's only been a month so
we'll keep you on this track and see
where you're at in six months or a year
i'll bet you you're gonna be very proud
of yourself
you have some good years ahead of you i
think you and your boys
i still haven't even watched the last
one you have to watch the video no i
keep saying that i'm going to but i just
i haven't
you don't have to it's your past yeah
you can watch it in 20 years
because you're leaving all that behind
hopefully
because there's nothing you were
involved in then that was worth hanging
on to
at all that's why i said just drop the
car drop the neighborhood drop the job
just walk away from everything
so you're you're starting a whole new
life now
and you look better
thank you
you're happier i hope
your boys aren't happier i'm sure of
that
a lot of good things are happening now
you're just making some some good
decisions for yourself
and that's not easy not everyone can do
that
it's definitely scary but
i mean
it's a lot
excuse me it's a lot in life that's
scary you know
you can't be comfortable all the time
yeah cause if you're comfortable all the
time that means you're not doing
something right
are you doing something
that you're too used to you know
and you're only gonna get
the same outcome if you're doing
something that you
too used to courage is very rare
and i think it's the missing
link in making
your life really work out the way you
wanted to
for all of us not just you everybody
you're doing it
i'm proud of you thank you
thank you for coming back israel
i will check in with you again
thank you very much
you